this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode he's going to be checking
out the zombie dispatching weapons of
back for blood at one nice touch i
noticed as the model was spinning you
see down the barrel and you can actually
see the plastic crimped ends of the
shotgun cartridges i do like it when
things are fully modelled
if there are any other games guns and
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below be sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and if you'd like to help out the royal
army's museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to jonathan
[Music]
okay m1a this is not a legally different
designation and it looks really good as
with most of the guns in the game
they've done a good job of modeling a
lot of the detail on this our example
here has the older style wooden stock
with a sheet metal
upper handguard polymer stocks like this
are
quite common now
wood um although it can look nice is
a pain to look after it absorbs moisture
it has to be regularly oiled or
lacquered or painted with something but
nice bits of walnut like this do require
a bit of care and they're actually more
expensive to get these things carved
finished maintained in the 70s ish most
military firearms switched over to
polymer like we see here but this is the
civilian version of the rifle now it
actually has
the ghost of where the selector switch
would have been fitted had this ever
been finished as an m14 now a weird
quirk of history is that although m14s
were made full auto capable very few
were ever issued with that switch the
vast majority had the switch physically
removed so that the rifleman could not
use this on automatic mode it was
recognized that it was
very little value yes you could hit fire
in a trench in an emergency but you only
have a 20 round magazine the thing jumps
around like crazy your sight picture
just goes if you are trying to aim from
the shoulder it just wasn't worth it and
so they stuck with what was essentially
a box magazine fed m1 garand
yes it's got a different gas system on
here big old bird cage flash hider which
is still here on the m1a but it is
essentially the the m1 garand lineage is
very clear to see the reload on this is
actually i find a little awkward but i'm
not a proficient user of the weapon so
you do have to be very positive getting
that in there and then getting it out
it's not difficult by any means but it's
not that modern um slam it in and forget
about it but we're so used to
seeing
interesting footnotes and a fair bit of
detail actually is that the accessories
that you fit to your your guns in this
game come in little
mock-up boxes which is quite nice
showing what they are with some
information looks like something you
might find on the shelf in a gun store
and then the corporate logo on there is
slam fire which is not a real company
but it is an allusion to a real thing in
the firearms world which is occasionally
deliberate so with some shot pump action
shotguns allow you to hold the trigger
down and slam fire so as the pump grip
goes forward it chambers and fires the
round which in theory with a fair bit of
practice means you can
whack out all of your shots a lot
quicker in practice very rarely used the
other meaning of it is not so good that
is when you release the bolt on a
firearm either manually or with a hold
open device or even actually if it's
running itself it's most worrying so the
gun is cycling say and as the bolt hits
home it fires itself without you pulling
the trigger it's called a slam fire
literally the bolt slams and fires and
then usually that will cause it to come
back again in some situations that can
create a runaway gun where it just
shoots itself until it's empty obviously
none of that is good so it's a slightly
ironic name i think for a firearms
accessories company because it kind of
implies that their stuff makes your gun
malfunction
it's probably worth noting that although
that bit of accessory rail for an
optical sight up here on the handguard
is i'm sure they exist it's not the best
place to be mounting a mount for an
optical sight this isn't really moving
much but i can feel it moving slightly
you would probably lose zero after a
while especially with the recoil of this
thing this is why well partly why the
m14 ebr and the other enhanced m14s were
stripped from their stocks and a whole
new chassis built for them
to incorporate a mount for an optical
site trying to retrospectively upgrade
things is often great but comes with its
challenges and that would be one of them
on me
okay good old zombie apocalypse staple
the pump action shotgun the remington
870 which we've seen so many times now
looks like a pretty good rendition of
that
fairly detailed despite the slightly
cartoony vibe of this game and of left
for dead the configuration here is
what's magpul furniture so it gives it a
almost a sci-fi edge really with the
angular butt stock polymer foregrip with
this with the stop ribs on it the heat
shield on top of the barrel is not
magpul and is not standard either
i believe that's an aftermarket thing
that would be if it was a real gun and
that is really just to help protect your
your hand should your fingers or contact
the barrel which in this scenario would
make a tremendous amount of sense
because the sheer number of rounds
you're putting through this thing the
sheer amount of heat means that
you actually would physically burn
yourself if you touch the barrel so it
doesn't make sense to have it on there
as much as a game like this makes any
sense reload is a little funky kind of
lobbing
cartridges into the magazine with the
thumb and in reality if you've ever
loaded a pump action shotgun you know
that it requires a very positive firm
push to seat that thing so the little
claw retains the round it doesn't
immediately bounce straight out but then
that's everything in this game is amped
up and super quick kind of charlie
chaplin levels of super speed in terms
of all of the handling all of the reload
because otherwise you just won't be able
to keep up with the action
another action movie favorite it's the
atchison aa12 automatic shotgun belief
derived from the deu usas 12 that runs
rather faster than this does so that's
perhaps
600 ish rounds per minute this thing is
about half that so i think the the rate
that's depicted here is accurate i
assume the idea there was to try and
tame the thing because automatic fire
from a shotgun is of questionable
utility at the best of times and pretty
uncontrollable with a load like buckshot
or slug which you're probably gonna have
to use to even get the thing to cycle so
fairly exotic the chances of you coming
across this in this kind of scenario are
pretty slim and it wouldn't certainly
wouldn't be my first choice the
reliability in this situation would be
pretty questionable finding ammunition
wouldn't necessarily be too hard
although it'd have to be the right shell
length the right load to actually cycle
the thing so that's that's a
consideration and it's just it's too too
finicky and there's no point in in full
auto i mean yeah in a scenario where you
have hordes of these things coming at
you it would be useful for it for a
brief period of time but then the reload
is going to be a faff as well the the
drum i mean the drum is a weak point in
terms of reliability anyway they're all
quite fiddly to get on it's got a bit of
a thompson sub machine gun loading
situation going on with a with a guide
rib that you have to align and if you're
stressed and panicking and tired not
great so if you were stuck with this i'd
say you'd probably be better off using
it on semi-automatic i always think a
measure of whether a game is vaguely
realistic or not is if you do better
with things on semi-automatic very few
games achieve that and why should they
it's not usually the point but i totally
get the zombie apocalypse appeal of the
aa-12
we need to get out of here
also expected of course the ak-47 i
won't get into the tired argument as to
whether ak-47 is a legitimate
designation or not i'll leave that to
the comment section most of us could
agree that this is not an ak-47 because
it is in fact an akm you can see the
configuration of the stamped receiver we
can see the characteristic dimple over
the magazine all looks good so although
we don't have a modern sighting system
built into this version we do have the
classic soviet era sight rail from the
old akm i guess we could call this now
and attach to that is an over the top of
the top cover picatinny rail mount and
then you put your optics on there so
nice to see that the ak is not being
artificially
kept down in terms of its capabilities
you absolutely would be able to make
single somewhat accurate shots like that
at that distance often the ak in video
games is sort of nerfed to being a
glorified submachine gun but that's not
the case here this this thing can hold
its own as a rifle in game the reload is
fine but
not recommended to
pull down on the magazine to remove it
that locking log is at the front and you
always want to push away to ensure that
the thing clears the magazine well and
comes off if you try and push pull like
that you're quite likely to fumble it
and get the magazine stuck if only
momentarily which would be very bad not
wrong per se but not advisable um for
those of you wishing to enter the zombie
apocalypse
for real um don't do that so a bit of an
odd pose there
or position and hold as they say in the
british army
which i wasn't in by the way um we've
got a slightly gangster tilt to the
weapon and i'm not entirely sure why if
you're in very tight quarters you might
have to tilt the weapon to fit in
whatever space you're in i can't imagine
a situation where that would be very
helpful
other than shooting around the left side
of a barrier or a wall or something of
that nature which we're not doing so it
seems to be a
stylistic choice i suppose i don't
really get it you would always want to
keep it in the shoulder looking through
the sight as normal whether you are
standing crouching or prone
oh sorry my bad
we've got a barrett i don't remember
having anything of that power level in
the old left 4 dead gains seems to work
well here essentially the heavy
artillery running around with this thing
shoulder firing it a bit less plausible
than it would be if it was an m82 or
m107 with this you've got a built-in
slower rate of fire having said that the
way the bolt handle is manipulated and i
won't embarrass myself by demonstrating
it but unless you are said unit you
probably aren't going to be flicking it
back and forth like a target rifle bolt
this is substantial powerful springs in
there you've got to get that forward and
down we don't really get the sense of
the meatiness of this design from the
animations that's the optics there's no
reason why you would have to have a
magnifying optical sight on this thing
that's its real world purpose of course
for reasonably long range shooting
explosive ordnance disposal
anti-materiel aircraft vehicles
structures radar dishes and sometimes
for shooting enemy personnel as well
usually that requires a fair bit of
magnification from a scope but in this
fictional scenario where you're using it
for essentially as a giant glorified
shotgun red dot is fine even the iron
sights probably fine you would be very
tired very quickly even if you were
quite sizable i think so with certain
weapon configurations this crouched down
tilt the weapon thing does make sense so
something like this barrett equipped
with its conventional long-range
magnified optic you only have two
options using that at close range it's
basically it's like try walking around
your your house with a pair of
binoculars or something it's not
sensible to be looking through a
magnified lens and trying to get around
at close quarters so you have two
options either look over the scope which
could be quite awkward with this thing
or count it over i think in this case
tilting it makes a certain amount of
sense why you'd only do that when
crouched though that doesn't
quite make sense
i'll take this
okay pause at 7 14. what the hell is
happening there looks like whenever you
eject a mag the slide magically goes to
the rear
am i seeing that right
right i don't know if it's a resident
evil connection but i think having a
beretta in a zombie game does take a few
boxes now this says beretta m9 it's not
an m9 because it has the accessory rail
under or on the dust cover under the
barrel but it's not an m9a1 because it
has the wrong shape of trigger guard
because when they added that rail they
reprofiled the trigger guard which used
to curve inwards like this one to be a
flat surface to mate with the back of
the light or laser module that you're
fitting so this is a curious hybrid of
m9 and m9a1 right a curious
oversight here with beretta
whenever we hit reload we which flick
out the magazine and magically the slide
leaps to the rear and locks open
regardless of the state of the weapon so
i'm hoping that gets fixed at some point
because that will be distracting to
nerds of a certain
stripe like me so it's even more of a
93r in
92 clothing than i thought because it's
actually three round burst only which is
exactly what the 93r does doesn't
actually allow for auto fire and neither
does this now if you're trying to kind
of gunsmith this thing to fire more than
one round quickly that's achievable for
fully automatic i don't think it would
be achievable but certainly not very
easily and not without leaving some
visible evidence on this on this gun to
turn it into a three-round burst
mechanism that requires widgets and
dewiki's
inside the gun that don't exist inside
this gun without getting into the
details of how you would make it fully
automatic of course it is substantially
more straightforward to look at doing
that i wouldn't raise too much of an
eyebrow if this thing was full auto i'm
raising both eyebrows at once
that it is very round burst
reloading
incoming
right so our third shotgun now the
benelli m4 super 90 semi-automatic
shotgun used for
military law enforcement competition
purposes this one's relatively vanilla
for for a modern um tactical shotgun i
mean if you had to take a shotgun into
this
level of frenetic combat of any kind
it's an excellent choice what doesn't
make a huge amount of sense and i
suspect this has been done deliberately
to elicit a comment
is a magnified optic on a shotgun not
entirely out of the question if you were
trying to deliver slugs at 50 meters or
more maybe you might want a magnified
optic to do that but it would hamper
your ability to use it as a close
quarters weapon
something else we can see through this
scope is the always-on tracers as i
think i'm going to start calling them
now which are not not just a video game
thing a movie thing every gun that fires
a shot has a tracer effect coming out of
it whether or not it's loaded with
traces and we see that weirdly up close
to the scope so we see several tracer
patterns of pieces of shot as they
emerge magnified out of the end of the
gun it's nice to say you wouldn't see
that in reality you probably see a
little a wisp of smoke and maybe an
effect on target and that would be it
so we have another
m4 that isn't an m4 here now it's very
close however because of the very high
resolution here we can see that is not
an issue lower receiver that is if this
was real either a dealer sample or
illicitly
produced
select fire ar15 lower receiver and it
has some sort of skull and crossbones
makers mark on there someone who's
played the game can tell us what it
actually says but it's not us government
issue this is a civilian configuration
of ar-15 but it is select fire
it's fully automatic it is
semi-automatic and obviously has the
safe position as well the reload is
interesting it's very slick we've got uh
drop the magazine magazine goes on and
then the thumb is held in a position
where we can immediately hit the bolt
release that's doable but you'd have to
have some skill to be able to pull that
off every time i mean the classic
example of an ar-15 reload which is
actually taught in or has been taught
anyway in military circles and law
enforcement circles is val kilmer's
reload in heat in the big street battle
where it's quite slow and deliberate but
sufficiently flawless that it's been
used as teaching material and you can
see there how the magazine goes on he's
probably tugging slightly to make sure
it's fitted and then he's separately
hitting the bolt release here it's all
done in a fluid motion
moving toward the station we'll keep an
eye on them and update you on the
situation as it
oh develops this is a bit of a greatest
hits of zombie slash action movie guns
of course we've got a deagle of course
we have now our 50 here is um it is a
mark 19 but it's not the latest version
that we see in bat for blood which has i
believe it's got the shorter barrel
assembly and it's got
built-in compensator ports up here on
the barrel and as far as mounting
magnifying optical sights on a pistol
which isn't usually very helpful unless
you are target shooting or maybe hunting
large creatures this is one of the
better
sort of ways to mount a site because the
slide's not banging back and forth and
messing up your accuracy not degrading
the actual sight in terms of actual
utility of this thing i'm not sure it's
it's not it's not the bomb proof
reliability of something like a glock
low capacity seven rounds of 50 action
express it's maybe not an ideal choice
and yes it's powerful
but it's not rifle level of power or
even shotgun level of power would you
bother um i mean you might find it it's
much more of a recreational firearm than
it is a practical one
i have fond memories of the um m16 from
left 4 dead and left 2 and we've got
another one here and it has been updated
it is either an m16 a3 or a4 the one
i've grabbed just makes life uh more
confusing because
this isn't even an m16a2 a and this will
break some some hearts for for um ar-15
enthusiasts but this is an old model 01
lower receiver with various bits of
m16a2 furniture and an m16a2 upper
receiver that has then had its carrying
handle cut off and a
uh
original nato spec rail
fitted to it and this as you haven't
already guessed this is british
experimentation in the 1980s
to see
how the very well proven world standard
m16
would fare
when fitted with a four power british
optical sight
so you don't often see an m16 with a
sunset on it so i thought i'd show it to
you so we have all the a2 features here
that i would expect except for
barrel is the wrong profile you can see
here this is the standard a2 heavy
profile barrel the flash hider is
weirdly stretched and the hand guard is
weirdly fat
you can probably see from from this one
everything looks a bit
beefy but otherwise it's kind of what
we'd expect to see a bit of a detail on
the m16 when we're looking through the
scope here we're looking we're looking
along the top of this classic ribbed
handguard and what we're not seeing are
these many
holes for cooling it just looks to be
it's the right sort of texture ish but
that should be drilled at the factory
with all of these holes
and they're not there so that hand guard
is a bit of an anomaly but what i
noticed more than anything else about
this and frankly everything else i've
seen so far it's the sheer amount of
gore all over your hands all over the
guns i think we do need to talk about
that briefly
brains
are not a test medium for military
rifles mud
sand water ice but not
blood brains
uh the sort of stuff that's flying
absolutely everywhere if you did slather
your firearm in
something of that texture shall we say
what would happen well i don't think it
would be good i especially don't think
the um
holding the thing on on the wonk like
this that we're seeing done in this game
that would not end well because the
stuff that's coming over the gun and
landing in this ejection port that's the
last place you want anything to be
landing and as you're firing it stuff is
going to be landing in there never mind
the fact that you might then get stuff
on the magazine and introduce it into
the magazine well that could end badly
too getting it on your left optics could
render them unusable and you'd have to
tilt it on the side and maybe that's the
point
so suffice to say zombie goo and
firearms would not mix
this is a very faithful as far as i can
see impression of the
us m249 scored automatic weapon variant
of the fn minimi
5.56 millimeter light machine gun uh you
can always spot the 249 because of the
upper hand guard which isn't usually
present on other
minimi variants it seems to work as it
ought to except that when we have the
thing tilted on the side there's some
some pretty worryingly lethargic case
ejection going on there i don't know if
it was a glitch but i've noticed that
when the player stops shooting the very
pretty column of spent cases coming
vertically up out of the gun
seems to just vanish into thin air
whatever was still in the air just
vanishes and if that's something that
might get fixed what of course i don't
think the game lets you do that you'll
be familiar with from things like
battlefield is actually provide any sort
of meaningful support fire the zombies
aren't going to react to being
suppressed anyway but you could
pick them off with you know short
controlled bursts and perhaps offer more
effective cover than running around with
the team blazing away from the hit but i
realize that doesn't support the
gameplay
of this particular game very well and
actually practically speaking you
probably just get left behind and eaten
or clawed to death or whatever while
you're lying down trying to lay down
fire
all right sawn off shotgun another one
from the tick list of weapons we would
expect to see in a zombie game now this
one i've picked here this is quite a
vintage piece 1880s would have been
actually quite a nice attractive
sporting shotgun at one time but it's
had a bit of a hard life and has then
had the barrels cut down for
some sort of criminal purpose this came
to us from one of the uk police forces
having been seized in a criminal
context but it does have what uh called
uh domestic damascus barrels where the
steel wire iron wire is twisted to
create the barrels would have looked
really nice originally the gun we see in
the game is well it's straight out doom
two isn't it it's it doesn't have the
the butt stock still in place which
really you would want for any kind of
serious use it's a classic sauna shotgun
store of barrels and sawn off stock and
it has the much more common top lever
does still have external hammers like
this one though and they're both 12 ball
or 12 gauge at one nice touch i noticed
as the model was spinning
uh you see down the barrel and you can
actually see the plastic crimped ends of
the shotgun cartridges i do like it when
things are fully modelled all working
parts in there doing their thing ideally
i realize it's not always necessary or
there's time for it but it's nice when
things are modeled as though they're
real two triggers on this as indeed on
um most double barrel shotguns not all
even when they only have one trigger
though it only fires one barrel first
then the next these are sporting purpose
firearms and the idea is to have two
shots to shoot birds clays whatever it
is
so these modified movie guns most likely
and certainly video game guns that go
off that set off both barrels with one
pull of the trigger you'd have to modify
the thing fairly significantly to get it
to do that as to why that one's called
the belgian well this one's a a british
maker but um belgium was a real gun
making hub for all sorts of different
guns of all sorts of different qualities
from very early in history all the way
up until well now and in the 19th
century uh early 20th century there were
lots of cheap belgian shotguns being
made so that may be why it's called the
belgian
right well this is a bit of a
gangster special intratech tech 9 or in
this case the interdynamic kg9 because
this thing kept getting reinvented
um designed originally as a machine
pistol in europe ended up as a
semi-automatic pistol although it looks
like a machine pistol for the u.s
self-defense market essentially fell
into the wrong hands frequently
it's a classic gang weapon it's not
amazing but it would be around in an
urban environment in the u.s if you were
to happen across firearms perhaps
converted to full auto i'm sure some of
them would be tech nines whether they
would run reliably is another matter
whether you could hit anything without a
shoulder stock is another matter we do
have sling loops on this one so you
could put it on a sling push it out for
some measure of control it's not likely
to be super accurate
and not necessarily super reliable
either but it does it does fit the world
i think in case anyone's thinking that
um this thing firing with the bolt
forward or closed bolt operation is
wrong
well it depends on the variance i mean
this one is actually
open bolt so it would fire and then blow
back most of the well the tech 9 as a
variant
was designed to be
semi-automatic only and therefore they
redesigned the bolt to be closed when
fired so they changed the whole design
inside in a way in a bid to make it
legally not readily convertible if that
makes sense the worry from the
authorities would it was it would be
easily converted to fully automatic
making it more of a very useful criminal
weapon usually when i point that nerdy
fact out it's because someone's modeled
the gun incorrectly in this case nope it
should be bolt forward and even if you
converted it to full auto it would still
fire from the closed bolt like that
oh careless
those were the guns of back full blood
which i will definitely be trying out at
some point as a veteran left for dead
fan thank you very much for watching as
always we've got the links in the
description for donations or
anything you might want to check out
from us over at the royal armouries
museum do come and visit us if you can
check out our social media
check out our youtube channel you might
find something of interest there
otherwise see you again next time
[Music]